[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
clowns on the inside some of us are
insane clowns on the outside uh this is
the daily nerdy news show that brings
you everything you need to know live
from the new rockstars headquarters here
in Los Angeles from our actual break
room I'm joined by uh Coy Eric and uh
Tommy tudope over here
I can't read what these garbage people
are trying to say to me just wait till
it updates and see all those emojis
we're gonna be in a day
uh on today's show we're going we got
some She-Hulk updates we've got a couple
real life spider verse actor updates
that are just
nuts restraint some of them are no nuts
yeah some of them have taken all the
nuts out of the situation some of the
bolts as well we're nuts about bolts
here uh we'll we'll explain that a
little bit later and uh mostly we're
going to be talking both we've got some
great Iron Heart discussion to have and
uh some Andor reaction stuff now three
episodes of vandar dropped late last
night yeah we assume you have not
watched all three we will not be
spoiling any of those episodes uh Tommy
recorded an interview with one of the
stars of Andor that we're gonna play
we'll have some kind of light discussion
there but we're gonna come back later in
the week and we'll we'll be talking more
Andor once everybody's had a chance to
uh talk indoors
no if
and or butts about it
Stellar what's what's the butt rating on
Andor oh all the butts okay even the
Droid asses are fine on Android
um and uh thank you to everybody though
our chat is maybe weirdly Frozen
um we assume you're in there
this is our first straight episode 101
is scoring a straight flag zero
uh zero concurrence for the first time
in our history uh but uh we appreciate
everybody that sends us a super chat
we'll try to answer those or call those
out and for every hundred dollars we get
in super chats we will be going to our
bucket of rants here are a bunch of
topics one of us will draw from one of
these topics and go on an epic yeah rant
we'll give you just for just a case just
a one line I'm gonna give you a one-line
rant first one's free this one let's say
it's rant on food why are you so
delicious okay
yeah we call those micro rants exactly
those are tiny little rants for our uh
for our Platinum level subscribers micro
Rants and micro pads
chat's fine on my end well we got the
same okay well I got some bad freaking
news for you it's nothing over here
we'll get some refresh going here in a
minute uh but first some headlines we've
got some fun headlines yeah
uh actually a lot of this is late
breaking this might be the first place
you've heard some of this uh just in the
last hour uh Fantastic Four has writers
now
that's necessary I'm told yeah see for a
film you typically need somebody to
write it um so you know at d23 they're
both Tommy and Chloe were in attendance
at uh Kevin feige confirmed that Matt
shackman was going to be directing the
film but we didn't know any other Talent
assigned to it uh but now deadline is
reporting that Jeff Kaplan and Ian
Springer will be writing the script now
those are not household names per se
they worked on the Palm Springs movie
good movie maybe Sandberg blind film
movie that a lot of people enjoyed
um good cinema
uh they've been working kind of in the
same orbit as
um what Watts uh John John Watts of
course of uh Spider-Man I like this
another comedian the comedy duo
seemingly they've had a lot of success
with comedy folks making Marvel uh
properties uh we're gonna say they were
working in the neighborhood of Watts
riding around oh yeah it's out that way
um
yeah and you know marvel films are
complicated there's often lots of
writers rewrites all kinds of stuff
involved but interesting right again
another sign the production on that is
moving forward we also acknowledge that
it's a good thing we didn't get a cast
before there were words to let people
audition with like yeah yeah there's a
process and I know that you have
archetypes and everything else but I'd
rather have the cast be cast with the
actual buttons
Badgley or Emily blood Jody covers
confirmed according to three weeks ago
internet yeah Alba is the second run
she's coming back it is it's uh it's
Schrodinger's Sue storm at this point
until we know for sure all of them are
shoe stores
I heard Johnny Storm is going to be
played by Anger from inside out I love
it he can already go what was Black
confirmed yeah Hades for the role oh he
did because James Wood
uh revealed the origins to her uh IRL
titanium marketing we've talked about
this on the show before she's showing up
in character in costume at like fashion
week and other events and places which
is awesome apparently uh there was a
quote that literally they ship her wig
around the country and then she shows up
I also I want the gig of just the person
who carries around
I want the merch wig on tour 2022 wink
tour yeah yeah yeah coming to a city
near you and she kind of just um said
that you know she's a real big fan
because the show breaks the fourth wall
she figured like oh it's even fun to do
that really right to break the actual
you know break through the screen and
take these characters out into the real
world she loved that previously when
Marvel actors and characters would kind
of maybe go on talk shows or uh cons and
things like that and it's great I mean
we should do more of this now maybe you
know Marvel characters that like have
weapons and stuff like that shouldn't be
showing up to shopping malls but you
know for the most part go out there and
have some fun I mean this is method
acting done right I like this get the
Punisher out there
but with Nerf guns yeah
uh speaking of She-Hulk um director Anu
Balia which I I've had to say her name
on a few episodes we're really getting
you here and I am butchering it each
time I could easily Google it and I keep
forgetting to apologies
um but she teased she did an interview
kind of teasing the rest of season one
and I think the you know it's a general
promotional interview where she's saying
there's some fun stuff coming but she
kept emphasizing this interview that
it's like it's gonna surprise people
it's not what you expect there's some
like interesting directions The Show
Goes and it's like well we've already
seen like you know this light tone it's
kind of like the breaking the fourth
wall some interesting choices so it's
like oh where could it go that now
surprises US based on that Cosmic hard R
dark
I mean maybe maybe it shows up I mean
there could be maybe there's some uh
like some some magic you know maybe
we've gotten the science part of it
maybe it's time for the magic to to take
in and I'm not talking Donnie Blaze I'm
talking like real magic
sounds courtroom drama no powers very
very
you can't handle the truth the big Law
and Order crossover that's happening
this week
if we see Mariska walk out on She-Hulk
we know things are about to go very good
Chris Maloney is still man I've been
saying still man for weeks
as Elliot Stabler yeah I've taken on a
life of crime and so has his cheeks his
daddy has changed you can handle the
stilts
that's right
um so we're excited for the rest of the
season again that episode dropping
tonight yeah next episode of that Series
so we're uh patiently awaiting the
surprises to come and then we've got a
new entry possibly in our thirsty
thesbians Hall of Fame uh this is a
Twist on Thursdays of course the phrase
we use to refer to any actor out there
angling uh you know working their way to
try to get more Marvel work usually
usually Marvel works it could be Star
Wars DC whatever but um we've got the uh
two directors who directed a few
episodes of Miss Marvel uh a deal lrb in
Bilal fala who also more famously and
more recently they were the directors of
the Batgirl film they got uh cut and
shelved and trashed dressed in Paradise
yeah
um but they put a post on Instagram that
was like a post about Miss Marvel it was
basically like hey who's excited for
season two yeah which is clearly the
answer is they are they love to work
well and I think both you and dashel had
great uh rather than thirsty thespians
we're referring to these as dehydrated
directors
parched producers
I can't take credit for that that was
all Zach and dash will be largely like
those shots that they made I I really
love their episodes of Miss Marvel
because that's the comic come to life
for me especially with the text and the
way they Incorporated the visual in that
pilot yeah yeah there's a lot of energy
in their stuff which is why like that's
the reason honestly I was the most
excited for Batgirl like I was more
excited for their directing and even
Keaton coming back because I thought
like what a great way to make Batgirl
feel different than Batman because you
don't want a shared Universe where every
Bat character is like okay Uncle Bruce
like there's that whole brain yeah yeah
you're going like purple and yellow and
dynamic and like a lot of people have
been clamoring for more of the 60s Adam
West like papow like I feel like they
could have done that and felt modern
because because they're visual
sensibilities so I'm actually hopeful
that this Marvel season 2 happens maybe
because Batgirl didn't happen like
because I was really excited for Batgirl
and I wanted that energy absolutely yeah
and you know we know we're seeing Kamala
Khan's character in the Marvels next
year uh and so presumably a second
season would come sometime after that
maybe we're talking 2024 or something
like that some Champions maybe some uh
Team Dynamics maybe the Young Avengers
Springs out of that oh yeah maybe maybe
that's even yes maybe that's even where
she shows up right maybe like Miss
Marvel season two is kind of a backdoor
pilot for instance because they'll need
a lot of story and I think the best
thing about the shows is you've got you
know some hours and especially after
Daredevil I think Daredevil is going to
show Marvel that we want more not less I
think a lot of people are like six
episodes of rushing and after we get
like this giant show we might actually
start to get 12 and 16 episode seasons
and that's how you'd lay the groundwork
for younger vendors like you'd want time
to live with these characters as a team
as opposed to two hours in the theater
yeah because we saw what happened with
aged Ultron like that's five movies and
it didn't quite work and they
retroactively made it work and then you
still watch Age of Ultron it's like why
is Thor tripping balls in a spa like
some things still don't work so I think
that a show would be a good way to tell
that story
Hemsworth didn't even know they were
filming that
um okay and then uh yeah I love all of
that and we're excited like there's
still a lot of holes in the Disney plus
schedule as far as series Marvel series
coming up especially after like next
year it's clearly they haven't renewed
things or they don't know exactly what's
going to go and so this Marvel season 2
is certainly a top Contender to show up
there but we've got two stories okay and
these are both wild yeah these are two
actors from the spumcy the uh Spider
Universe there uh with some weird
real-life stuff going on something's
going on over in the spum see uh Tom
Hardy Venom himself okay Bane as well
um he apparently showed up to a an
actual Brazilian Jiu Jitsu competition
in England and one yeah uh this is not
the first time he's done this he has won
multiple like and this isn't like the
national championships this isn't like
an Olympic qualifier or something like
that it just shows up to a small town in
England enter unannounced enters a um
high school gym yeah and there's a uh a
jiu jitsu contest under his name Edward
Hardy I guess that's his legal name Ed
Hardy oh my God
it makes sometimes that's why it goes by
Tom
um uh anyone and apparently t-shirts
perhaps you'd like to buy one of mine
with a snake and a dagger running
through more of a Dazzle out and you
know there's a long history of of uh
action actors being into Combat Sports
in real life most of them lying though
yeah usually it's your Mickey Roark your
Jason Statham where they kind of like
train in these things
[Laughter]
yeah but I I love this and apparently oh
man everybody there is like he's the
nicest guy he would like before there's
one competitor that was like who was
who's gonna be matched against Hardy and
he was like he told me uh just forget
it's me and do what you normally do
which like yeah okay easier said than
done time already you're the famous guy
yeah
[Music]
this is a weird story for me because
this is the first time I felt like I
Knew Too Much about an actor because his
entire Instagram is just BJJ like
symbols and training and stuff so this
news broke and everybody's like Tom
Hardy bubble but I was like he's been
doing that for years and it was the
first time I was like am I too invested
in Tom Hardy because it felt like
nothing news I'm like I just saw him
last week training blah blah blah I was
like oh I I've gone too far yeah I felt
like TMZ for the first time where I was
like I love Tom Hardy so much I'm like
of course he won he's the person years
ago yeah yeah I I I watched it live on
his igp yeah I flew back from England
this morning but I love it if someone
else entered a bit of a competition wow
okay so the other crazy the other crazy
bit of news and I don't know this kind
of actually broke because the Drew
Barrymore's reaction to this actually
got more traction than the original
quote but Andrew Garfield The Amazing
Spider-Man yeah uh he was doing an
interview where he talked about a
previous role he was in that Martin
Scorsese film Silence with
um Liam Neeson and some other folks
where he played a monk like in in
ancient Japan kind of stuff and he said
that he was doing method acting for that
and so he abstained from any sex for six
months six months in preparation for
that film now the joke was and Drew
Barrymore's already made this joke like
six months so what yeah people
accidentally go six months about sex all
the time right but if you're handsome
Andrew Garfield maybe that's a bigger
Endeavor he's like look I [ __ ] so this
is hard for me like my penis
hard joke was the pun I never heard the
quotes I thought whatever I read it I
was like Drew Barrymore was making a did
you right I was like proud I thought
like it's hard and then I realized that
is not the context in this moment
and I I do love idea of like what is and
you know method acting is a bit
controversial in the acting world so
sometimes it it causes people to like oh
I'm playing a chef so I'll go work in a
kitchen for a month and sometimes it
causes Jared Leto to like male people
pick hearts and stuff like that so
there's a there's a wide variety yeah
just slashed my tires again yeah why the
movie ended 10 years ago
but like
but like I I mean and of course he did
this for like a more like heavy serious
dramatic role what is and it's tough for
Marvel actors you can't go method as
Captain Marvel or something like that
you know I shouldn't like fly through
his face or something like that I'm
jumping out of this plane free you don't
have a parachute I don't need one
tragedy today
method acting going wrong more than 11.
it's like yeah exactly and now I think
was it you Tommy or uh Brandon who made
the joke of like starting no not
November that was Brandon I gotta give
him credit where credits too you know
have fun with that maybe you started
last November
you're doing it he's committed to it
if you're Andrew Garfield's partner
during that window yeah you're also
committing to abstinence and you're not
even getting to act in the role right
he's like sorry that's true I've got to
make my acting dollars
nobody will be able to tell right nobody
watching Silence was like that's an
actor isn't it does that movie come out
yet yeah it's years ago it was
pre-pandemic okay that shows how much I
care about movies that aren't Marvel
obviously but I will say this I saw the
trailer for silence and I noticed I said
I said that's a guy that's full that's a
full thing that is that that's that
guy's that guy's got it first that guy
that guy's in need of
hey guys making small decisions every
day to help the planet could have a big
impact over time if you keep your money
in most standard bank accounts they're
lending your deposits out to fund oil
and coal yuck switch to the planet side
and get aspiration and by the way thank
you aspiration for sponsoring the break
room this week you have given me the
aspirations to get my money out of those
dang Banks buying all this oil and put
it into an aspiration account it's a
climate-friendly alternative to Big
Banks get an account in a debit card
that is fossil fuel free you can even
plant a tree by rounding up every swipe
of your debit card swipe swipe plant
plant aspirations been hard at work
funding the planning of over 100
million trees on their way exactly to
the funding plant funding of the
planting of one Burien trees by 2030.
best of all there's no credit check no
overdraft fees thank God and with the
aspiration and with aspiration you just
pay what you think is fair even if
that's zero but what kind of person pays
zero maybe me because money shouldn't
stand in the way of doing the right
thing
make your dollars make a difference open
an aspiration account at aspiration.com
breakroom debit and move your money out
of fossil fuels dang it saved the Earth
for crying out loud help save the planet
of your aspiration debit card open your
account at aspiration.com break room
debit today that is
aspiration.com break room debit use that
code guys it helps us it helps them
terms and conditions apply
uh we do have the I believe the chat is
working now we really missed out by not
having it live while we were talking
about Andrew Garfield and yeah and his
water balloon balls
water balloons in the chat
any balloons will do
yeah a splash and
uh but um
to the the main topic of this video
um right one of the upcoming Disney plus
series uh a character that's going to be
introduced in the next Disney and the
next Marvel film Riri Williams ironheart
uh there's been kind of some news
trickling out we got some footage at d23
that's right we've got to see a little
bit of a teaser trailer yeah
I like the style of it a lot more than I
expected yes I knew that character in
the comic was on my favorites but I was
worried about the sensibility blending
with the Disney plus sensibility but I
was impressed
um and the footage was from the
ironheart series or was from uh Black
Panther it was from the ironheart series
yeah great and we just got our first two
dollars of the show guys we're talking
about abstinence we're talking about Jiu
Jitsu we're two dollars in halfway
through What's Happening Here what's
happening y'all got too excited for the
100th episode so it looks like that it's
two bucks like I like that it's like you
know two dollars you know what I hope we
get no more than two for them I hope we
freeze right there I just I just meant
the pair of dollars
Andrew Garfield swollen balls all right
that's right uh Coy and I were at d23 it
was like no it was the team that it was
a fully an iron heart teaser trailer
well I had nothing it wasn't uh
additional black panther uh what kind of
forever material it was all uh it was
all Riri and the Gang uh Anthony Ramos
came out uh to uh to talk about it I was
a little disappointed because they did
the musical number at the top but I'm
like you had Anthony Ramos yeah
how did you not get him to do Rogers the
musical yeah headed out right back yeah
he's like I'm not a clown you won't make
me dance for you he's like yeah you got
an extra million dollars you know who is
a clown
okay they threw it already oh
okay that's not his name but it could be
that's a good clown name I like that the
hood actually like one of the main
takeaways I got is the hood looked
better than he is in the comics yeah
yeah but Anthony Ramos was able to give
a bit of credibility to the character
that in the comics I'm like okay he does
magic quality of guns like there's
there's a certain like this medium works
and it doesn't translate and I was
worried about that character and then
what they did was they actually they
playfully changed riri's origin to tie
into the Hood's origin yeah and her
motivation is different than in the
comics at least in this Arc because of
the hood and that makes comic fans that
know the character really well like
that's intriguing so what I liked about
the footage was it didn't feel like it
was pandering to the Iron Man crowd or
to the Young Avengers crowd we've had so
far it feels like a very different more
you know Punisher Daredevil street level
show but yeah it feels it feels very
street level but young which I don't
think we've really seen yet because even
Miss Marvel that's more of a family show
and the the powers are extravagant and
literally sparkly this feels like it
could happen like this feels very like
tangible which I wasn't expecting yeah I
thought it looked really good I thought
I thought the inclusion of like uh the
hood and like clearly putting together a
team of people that we have yet to kind
of figure out who they're all going to
be but remember there was all those
casting announcements that was like this
actor this actor whoa JT Ty's getting us
in on the rant train whoa much
appreciated GT we'll get there as soon
as we get done with this discussion but
uh there was like that looked really
good to me uh I think uh what Anthony
Ramos in the interviewer when he came
out he said this is the intersection of
the science versus magic so it's like to
me that's what's exciting because we've
talked about on the show before we've
been theorizing all of these mystical
magical projects have come out in in
phase four and we're kind of waiting for
the science of the earlier phases I mean
there's some magic in those as well to
kind of converge in what is probably
going to be pushing phase five along
right Doom is so magic in science right
because you've got basically read
Richards plus doctor that's right like
that's what do is King is technically
all science but science to the point of
magic kind of right yeah which is how I
think they're gonna Bond I think doom
and Kang are going to be very like
simpatic of how they see the World of
Magic yes
um yeah that's great and one thing we're
kind of sparked this conversation
there's been these rumors going around
about like a particular suit that iron
heart is gonna have right that's going
to be very it's like red which is kind
of nice with the heart aspect of the
title and like but looks very Advanced
right like very like Iron Man you know
not in the cave like way after the cave
right Mark Mach 5 or whatever yeah um
and I know obviously in the wakanda
forever trailer we see her kind of
stamping out a very rough kind of uh raw
iron kind of look a box of scraps yeah
and in the footage they played a d23
there's it seemed like something in the
middle yeah it felt like another suit
that we hadn't quite seen that was you
know beyond the cave but not to the you
know Top Gun suit right yes and so right
like are we going to get part part of
this Sparks us like oh where is the
ironheart series set in the timeline
because like if if she's already going
through multiple generations of suit in
wakanda forever yeah right are we then
is is ironheart the series is set all
after wakanda forever she's already got
the super advanced suit she's basically
full-blown Iron Heart maybe we were kind
of speculating before could it be a
little bit of both could it be a little
prequel and sequel that's what I mean
they call me Tommy half measures you
know that they've always Zach you've
known me a long time they've always
caught in the streets I've always been
known as Tommy half measures amongst
many other things I think that this show
will straddle the uh before wakanda
forever and after I believe in the show
it will acknowledge the events of
wakanda forever in like episode three or
episode four propelling us through the
rest of the show that's my prediction
that's my hot take I'm thinking we get
the ambassador program in wakanda and
that's a Reach Out program so maybe
she's fresh out of high school in
wakanda forever and then something
occurs in what kind of forever that puts
her in the MIT where the comic takes
place so maybe like the the prequel we
do straddle but it sort of flashbacks to
her life before because you don't want
to take too much black panther screen
time up with a character that's getting
her own show in like three months so I
think they need to give her a great
introduction interior to her which I
think they're gonna do one of the things
I was so impressed by was the actress
Riri Williams came out on stage and she
said like five things and all of it
sounded like reread to me it sounded
like that that Bendis ionic pentameter
dialogue like she has this this
quippiness this whip smart that is so
entitled to the character like
Spider-Man talks differently between
Toby Andrew and Tom to me there's a
different flavor to each like to me Toby
represents the way we were able to
digest the character in movies Andrew is
the comic come to life and Tom Holland
is the best version of an Avenger turns
Spiderman those all have different
cadences they all speak differently to
me hearing Gregory Williams I was like
oh that's the comic that's the Bendis
comic so I think we're gonna immediately
love her in ironheart and then when you
have the show you're gonna be able to do
hey this is how you are endeared to her
this is where she got these ideas and
then we get her to college because of
whatever ambassadorship she gets so I
think it's kind of straddle but I think
it's gonna be like an 80 20 split
it's also interesting if if she's
already gonna be on her third generation
because again the rumors are that in
wakanda Forever she's in this very
finished uh fancy Advanced suit so like
for getting through multiple generations
of suit during the film like that makes
you wonder a is there maybe a time Jump
In wakanda Forever right is that maybe a
post-credit scene suit or something like
that and then and it takes place over
that five-year blip what if her five
years is developing the suits she gets
it before the blip a lot of people go
away she's got five years of or or yeah
I love that idea also like what if Riri
is just like hyperspeed Tony Stark just
be like Monday uh box of scraps Tuesday
Wednesday Mark three okay I think we're
done here yeah or or like is soon as she
gets to wakanda it's like oh now I got
the good I get the good Tech yeah I can
I can move a lot faster now than
whenever I was back home or whatever
yeah I think vibranium is going to be a
key factor in her suit but that also
makes me wonder my theory about
vibranium going inert right like I do
think there's going to be an element
where vibranium gets out to the world
and you see there's a courtroom scene we
got to see where basically she's saying
no you guys don't get her vibranium blah
blah and I'm wondering if if people
steal vibranium and wakanda has to
basically say like okay no more
vibranium they they render a nurse that
does happen in the comics and then
Doom's able to take over so there's a
precedent so maybe there's something
where she has a vibranium suit it gets
rendered she has to build around look at
all these links are they sneaky links
I see a lot of people in the chat have
been saying that they've gotten both
their mugs I'm obviously wearing my mug
of choice wait wait that's the opposite
wait a second that's my mug and what's
going on here this is the official mug
of uh the break room the mandatory fun
mug and this is an antique that is a
yeah you can no longer purchase that of
course it was my design Marvin time
um your personal design my personal
design I I that was from my box of
scraps I'm gonna get my uh my my ranting
microphone oh okay yeah Tommy is uh I
was juicing up for a a rant of Epic
Proportions we're already on our way to
a second rant yeah uh maybe once you get
your whistle wedded by Tommy's uh
by Tommy's flavor let's see here push
people to another one rant on a brand
okay all right all right I gotta say
something to all you people out there
today this is a rant that's gonna get a
little personal oh I'm talking to you
target I'm talking to you target about
your clothing departments I went to
Target today to purchase some Japanese
barbecue sauce as you know I'm a fan yes
no secret I also went and looked for
some cotton candy grapes sold out oh
Japanese barbecue sauce one bottle left
grab the last bottle nice
on my way downstairs I looked at the
female section and every sign was like
bodies of all shapes and sizes are
beautiful gorgeous Queen you're a queen
of any size you're a gorgeous lady at
any size and then that's right that's
true by the way it does you're beautiful
people are beautiful no matter what it's
what it's What You're Made Of that makes
you beautiful you get up to the men's
section they're like you're not a
Nirvana black T-shirt men's medium get
the [ __ ] out of our store leave our
store fatty there's no the mannequins
are all chiseled V handsome manic I was
running my hands down their abs just to
make sure that all the female mannequins
all shapes and sizes you know you got
your thick female mannequin beautiful
skinny female mannequin beautiful you
know all beautiful mannequins get to the
men's it's just it's just all [ __ ]
Zac Efron mannequins where are the big
clothes at Target I gotta order online I
can't wait for the mail most male
doesn't make it to my house I got
thieves in my neighborhood okay I can't
trust the mail
and I can't trust Target oh thank you
Tommy okay good man hurry up the Grant
come on the show Target you cowards
defend yourself send that dog and your
size again
I hope that dog was euthanized oh my God
it had nothing to do with that party
shirt that dog picked out all their
shirt sizes that dog was like only women
can go up to Plus Sizes men must remain
that rant was both authentic and
heartfelt we appreciate you and we
appreciate Jason morante well-rounded
mom uh cloudy the gray JT ties
appreciate all of you a couple good uh
questions there uh Jason morante saying
koi what's your favorite secret Invasion
tie-in how do you think uh they will uh
pull the tie-ins off cinematically
that's almost a full episode worth of
discussion
um in brief yes the shows I I think the
reason we're doing a secret invasion is
it's a show and you can basically make
each uh B plot a tie-in issue right so
like your your a plot is going to be the
secret Invasion comic and then your B
plot is going to be like certain
characters getting their own time to
shine uh my favorite tie-in was the
Jessica Drew
um concept of her basically being a spy
that had to come to terms with her
family being spies and then we realized
that Jessica Drew's been a scroll the
whole time so we're like do we trust
this character that's already
duplicitous and then us after secret
Invasion having to learn to trust
Jessica Drew and her having to learn to
like basically accept that people don't
know how to believe in her uh which then
led to one of my favorite Jessica Drew
runs of all time where she's a single
mom and it's this really cool idea of
like Jessica Drew as a mom having to
take care of like a baby and babysitters
while also like defending the world and
like where her priorities are because my
mom like was a Teen Mom and she had me
so I've always been I've always wanted
more moms in comics uh and this was a
really cool way of showing like how much
moms have to do so uh Jessica Drew
spinning out of secret Invasion um meant
a lot to me so that's my that's my
answer I like that a lot of uh both our
mods Chrissy and frago reminding us that
the dog's name was Bullseye which is
also what the hunter that killed
Bullseye had to hit the football side
down straight in between a great
Daredevil villain as well
um uh well random I'm saying I can't
wait to see Anthony Ramos as a villain
I'm such a Hamill fan yeah uh I've only
ever seen him in Hamilton and in the
Heights so I'm excited to see him I mean
without him breaking out into song I'm
not sure I can handle it you can wait a
long time can you handle it
um okay uh and then real quick we want
to thank another sponsor of the show uh
I want to talk about uh this is not a
rant but it could be uh I like to call
it's a term I like to call sad swag okay
everybody likes free stuff when you get
free stuff from work or convention or an
event hey it's great and real it's free
it's a great price uh but when that free
stuff is junk yeah it's kind of sad you
know what I mean when the T-shirt
instantly falls apart when the the
graphic is falling off of it when the
mug is is junk and I like this mug or
more accurately this smoke uh it's sad
swag and it really runs the impact the
promotional uh part of of Swag the um uh
the happiness that we usually feel from
getting free stuff so if you don't want
sag swag sad swag in your life uh take
it from sad Zach uh get go to Land's End
okay uh one of the sponsors of today's
show Lands End Business uh does this
Great a great job making Shirts Mugs
hats all kinds of apparel for businesses
want to give it out to their employees
or give it out at events right super
high quality stuff uh that's great for
promoting your brand you can have their
logo and Vivid colors on all kinds of
products hundreds of products really
good for holiday gifts coming up right
around the corner if you're a boss and
you're not already working on getting
your employees some nice holiday gifts
listen up Philip Philip we could all use
some khakis with Zach's name amount of
granddaughter yes
zachies
whoa we got a new sponsor we are made of
100
baby deer skins Jackie's khakis where
will you eat tackies
but uh we're back a pack of khakis in
the front of my zachies khakis how wacky
uh they got great rights itself they got
great customer service over there at
lanzan you always uh they quick to
respond via email phone whatever uh see
why thousands of companies count on
Lands End Business go to
business.landsand.com podcast use promo
code podcast for 25 off hey that means
you could get 25 more swag or you can
get swag for the 25 of your employees
you don't really like yeah and you
aren't going to get it for him but now
you can afford it
um so that's
business.landsend.com podcast promo code
cast for 25 off thank you to aspiration
and Lands End for helping us bring this
show to you uh Tommy uh yeah hmm it's
time for mandatory fun hit the graphics
yes mandatory fun the segment so
spectacular we've worked it into our
vernacular hypnographic again
oh my God
this segment was so much a plum the
teens are all saying it's the bombing
again
we love this segment from one body part
to another right how would you say that
yes from our Spinners to our [ __ ] we
love mandatory fun hit the graphic again
see that's money you say it that way
because I've heard you say it a
different way yes from our drinkers to
our smelly stinkers hit it again from
our beakers to our squeakers from our
howlers to our own growlers from our
from our sniffers to our quiffers
for the ladies uh all right now anyway
uh this is the segment uh that gets so
unspun it makes me miss my son call me
Jeffrey Junior hit it again it was
Jeffrey senior yeah that's the mystery
all right now we've lost control I've
once again lost control from my thinker
to my plink blinker uh that's when you
get the little rabbit pellets when you
take a jog or something and then you
gotta go uh all right a meerkat if you
will yeah you got it we've got our
She-Hulk predictions and uh here's an
update of the standings I actually had a
dash will make a pretty high-tech
graphic here it's a piece of notebook
paper the current scores
Zach
with 31. okay this is nice respectable
Tommy Beck told with 30. okay Erica wusu
with 30. okay corjandro
with 36.
30 tight I'm tied with trash I've never
been so mortified in my life buddy Eric
I'm confident that you're in the bin
with me but right now Eric and I are
dumpster diving with you trash people so
this week we're gonna blow the
predictions out a little bit okay first
question uh I want to know guys we're
going to make this Price is Right rule
so if you go over you're out what is the
total episode length including the
credits for this week's episode for this
week's episode
do you remember what you told dashel I
think I said 32 and a half minutes all
right 32 and a half minutes all right I
went 28 28. oh okay including credits 10
credits wow I I kind of split the
difference I said 31 flat we'll see yeah
and I think it's gonna be a long one
guys I said 42 minutes and 33. zero
chance that is 40 pizzas for 40 days
no they're going deep so if it's under
29 minutes I get it right if it's over
35 minutes I get it because you fools I
went early okay
you said presidentials if you go over
you lose
I've made a mistake okay
zero minutes
36 34 28 only if she's five one
what a brick house
tuna can I
no we know we're assuming Daredevil is
going to make it into this episode uh do
we think She-Hulk and Daredevil are
gonna do any coupling you know and a
quick point of clarification yeah if
Jennifer and Matt do coupling yeah it
doesn't count doesn't it seems to be in
character hookup costume okay
I think there's gonna be flirting yes
but I don't think coupling yeah I think
there's like I don't think we're gonna
actually see any you know
smash but I do think we're gonna get a
little bit of uh he's a man without fear
he's gonna go for it yeah absolutely
climb her like a tree I think they gonna
couple yeah
hardcore that right he's The Man Without
Fear yes I want that for him yeah I like
that and she Stout like a beer that's
right I'm saying I'm gonna go no like
I'm thinking flirting no hurting yeah I
said no but I really hope it does happen
and I hope that I'd like to be wrong I
hope the good Folks at wood rocket make
a parody video of it uh anyway it exists
okay now uh finally which Luke Jacobson
who was of course the uh the costume
maker from last week's episode which
Luke Jacobson or outfit do we think
we're gonna see first now remember with
the options the business suit the
evening gown the hero suit something
else we know we've made her probably at
least three outfits right so what do you
guys think for that I'm gonna start with
business suit I think the first thing we
see is we we're going to see her in a
courtroom in a place of work and then
the evolution is going to be seeing the
ability of the the hero suit grow and
Shrink but I think you need to start
with the business suit to show his
skills in a different way plus we've
seen her the most in that really baggy
business
I'm going business too okay I said the
hero suit yo the bicycle shorts the
purple and black I said I said the
iconic hero suit okay yeah purple and
white I think so too I know usually
Disney Plus shows and Marvel shows wait
till the end of the first season to
Premiere the the finished hero suit but
this show breaks all kinds of rules
Jessica is gonna show up in the purple
shoot this is really soon yeah uh I I
like that and there's definitely a like
this show also right obviously it's
getting released weekly but like it's
also designed to be binged or as as most
streaming series are so you could see
like you finished episode five you go
right into episode six she just got her
suits the very next scene maybe she's
showing off from Nikki right in the cool
news but I too am going to say the
business too because I think we probably
start in the courtroom as we have or or
a GLK and H as we have a lot of the
episodes yeah
um so those are our picks those are our
picks those are good we're going to keep
those we'll get those tallied up we've
asked of course some of our friends who
are not here today with us to make their
picks Jessica Brandy and John somewhere
in Spain uh olaying a bowl don't go and
try and find them if you're in Spain
he's uh wearing his invisibility clothes
okay yeah any any Spaniards in the chat
uh let us know if you if you've spotted
John Costa yeah please we're worried
yeah please let us know
we we miss him uh uh so all right now
this is rare we've got time for our
discussion number two oh look at that
we're going to talk about Andor because
I mean now that the show is out the
jokes can stop that show slaps it is so
good I'm not a sus simp I'm not basic
I'm not choogy I'm not any of those
other things I said yesterday that are
words I don't understand and need a
teenager to explain to me I love Andor
okay I've enjoyed all three episodes
I know not other people have gotten a
joint we're only going to talk about the
first episode and we're not going to
spoil anything we may not even get too
far into the first episode here I was
lucky last week that every other person
that would possibly do a junket
interview at this company was it was
like one of those things where like the
whole team gets food poisoning and the
kid with like a little limp has to be
the kicker I was the limping kicker and
I got to interview a few people from the
cast of Andor uh specifically Fiona Shaw
um and as the person whose interview
we're gonna show today because I just
want to show a little clip of what it
was like to talk to Aunt Petunia who now
plays Marva on the show and or so we
have that clip hi Tommy Beck told new
rock stars hi Tony nice to meet you Miss
John what an honor it is I gotta say I'm
a massive fan I'm sure you heard that
all day but uh I I I I got I'm going to
start off with a two-parter we'll see if
we could we could come at you fast and
furious here when you were doing scenes
with B2 emo B2 emo as I like to call
them where uh was was there a voice
actor there on set and did you and Tony
Gilroy work some sort of background uh
backing story with the two of you like
how you got the Droid how you became
Pals well we meet I mean you meet
Barbara you know very old in her life we
meet her old sick and um she's obviously
at the story a long time and then you
know later you see her with the Droid
many years earlier when she was young
and and that's been part of the pleasure
of playing it that you get a chance to
play somebody owed somebody young in her
life and the Droid was much younger and
freshmen but you know Tony wrote it so
well that you really knew uh all the
time that the the Droid is Way Beyond
droidville this Droid has absorbed
information and has absorbed the moods
of the people that that that the Droid
works for so I love working with b and
the fact that b now needs to plug in a
lot and uh recharge a lot because it
isn't what it was yeah I agree I think
you've aged much better than the DROID I
think the Droid took some hard years I
thought you didn't know
so yeah yeah so you know there'd be more
you look for Eric's breakdown of episode
three for uh interview with Kyle Solaire
and more of my interview with Fiona Shaw
coming out I believe tomorrow uh he he
uh he snipped some Snippets from that as
well so you know the the rest of those
interviews will be popping up hopefully
more on the break room and In Our Star
Wars content uh yes that was the most
serious I've ever been in my life yes I
almost blacked out did you make Fiona do
a mandatory fund I did we had a little
mandatory fun that night at the drawing
room if you know what I'm saying oh my
God it's very interesting that everyone
else became incapacitated to conduct
this interview yes I have no comment on
that don't drink the soup
a lot of people pointing out that I come
combed my hair and I actually put on a
couch yeah well you know what guys
Miracles can happen Okay real real quick
Tommy so the the first three episodes of
vandor dropped last night again probably
a lot of our audiences not had even that
want to watch it if not have time yet to
watch it they'll probably be watching in
the next day or two uh is there
something people should keep an eye out
for in those first three episodes I
think the most fun uh thing about it is
there's this like special shorthand
language that everyone uh you know in in
the town of ferricks in the in the
planet of or whatever wherever supposed
to be the the moon of fairies wherever
the city that they're in has this
special language that's like shorthand
for being in the Rebellion so look for
the moments where people are saying one
thing and meaning another because I feel
like they're all going to pay off uh and
I think also just enjoy the great
characters the the you know Star Wars
does a great job of casting these just
like people that you haven't really seen
before or maybe have seen in something
so completely different that you don't
even you can't you're like how the heck
do I know this guy there's a great guy
who plays part of the um the uh private
security firm that's hired by the Empire
to kind of guard this area and he's just
this like stocky little Bulldog of a man
but he's such a company like like lick
spittle like he's like oh he's so
positive about the company and I he's my
favorite he's the white shirt yes he is
that's what they that's what the
internet is calling him the Dwight
Schrute uh of Star Wars and he's he's
incredible so there's so much to look
forward to I don't want to spoil anybody
because I want you guys to have a chance
to watch it on your own but I you know
this is you know a star Star Wars is so
enjoyable for me I I'm such a fan of the
franchise but this is something fresh
there's a fresh take on it a fresh
version of it it's like it's got
elements of Blade Runner it's got
elements of the wire weirdly or a show
where there's like you know low-level
operations all the way up to higher
level operations it's got all these
grounded elements in a galaxy far far
away so please and we've been talking
about like I don't think the the the
promotional power has not been put into
this show like maybe House of the Dragon
rings of power some other big shows that
have come out recently so I think it's
going to be a slow burn I think people
are going to hear by word of mouth and
like are slowly gonna be like dude if
you've seen this new Star Wars show it's
awesome right and like the popularity is
really going to grow over time so I will
be talking about all the episodes over
time here on the show again it's weird
when they drop three at a time because
it's a little impractical for us for you
to catch up but in future weeks as they
come out on Wednesday uh Tuesday nights
into Wednesday mornings we'll be talking
about the show uh we want to talk about
a couple polls
um I love this one it we did a poll in
the chat there it's going six months
without sex worth bragging about
72 saying no yeah yeah again a lot of a
lot of folks involuntarily have gone
that long without really thinking if
that's what
oh wait that's not possible Tommy um
everybody loves koi's predictions for
tonight's She-Hulk direct disrespect wow
I think this is the most the audience
has ever gone with me though usually I'm
below pulling below 10 is my campaign
getting a little bit of a push oh is
this is this what they call the Andor
bounce that's the first time I didn't
mention stilt man I think the audience
is just excited about that oh and we
will be updating uh I think probably on
Friday we'll be updating the Andor
fantasy which is a bit of my uh it's me
kind of just making all of my minions
dance for me uh for foreign
we've got a couple great other super
chats we're going to call it real quick
uh our friend Chrissy is back she kicked
kovitz ass and yeah
good to hear that you're you're doing
well uh she said you've you've been
given 50 pounds of Rob by raw vibranium
what do you make first oh I would say uh
a sale to somebody who's willing to buy
50 pounds yeah
like a sailing sound that seems
impractical I think yeah I it would it
would not be practical I would probably
make one of those saucers that you can
sled down because it's kind of a cap
Shield too but then you also sit on it
and you probably go really fast you
bounce off the trees and nobody can
bully you because you're going so fast
and they can't be like you sit in the
front so we go faster you see the fence
we go faster because it's just you on
the saucer and nobody can bully you and
it's just better that way and you're all
by yourself
nobody can bully you these are very
practical uses of 50 pounds of vibranium
I I would definitely make anal beads and
try them out myself
very indestructible booty beads in the
chat
I thought this was the horny episode 50
pounds every episode
come on let's get Jack give it to him
camera four My secret is
I'm always horny
uh koi what's your vibranium I think I
would make some sort of flying Tech I
like maybe I mean I don't know if I
could add the engineering for I could
give like five pounds to someone that
could engineer 45 pounds too like I feel
like I could make that happen I want to
be hired man adjacent or at least kite
man or just make a blend of vibranium
and steel you know just like be like
coat the steel and the vibrania you
don't want to step on the vibranium
unless I put an Ex-Lax in but yeah you
definitely don't want to cut it what is
this what is this
hey guys I just want to fly you you pay
a little bit less it's a little bit
stepped on it's fine
yet still gets the trick done Hollywood
not guilty
um
speaking of uh wakandan uh elements DK
uh I'm probably butchering your name I I
apologize but uh do you think killmonger
will return and how do you think it
could happen if it does well we know he
has returned via animation in what if
season one maybe we maybe he's still
there what if season two yeah I think
it's in the astral plane right like the
ancestral plane sorry I think he's in
the ancestral plane he's been a black
panther so he'd be welcome there yeah uh
I think that Michael B Jordan as an
actor being so close with Chadwick would
want to be there and honor his friend uh
so I feel like there's a place both in
our narrative and the comic narrative
that would fit it and I would love to
see you know he he had a moment of of
not Redemption but um The Clarity where
he felt both Justified and understanding
of both perspectives like I really love
killmonger's last moments where he you
know at the end of the day t'challa did
what he said like t'challa was like you
were right like you know he did it in
his own way and it wasn't his violent
but I think he's earned his place uh
amongst the Panthers to a point that I
think we'll see him yeah by the way if
you put 50 pounds of vibranium up here
but you will end up on the ass stroke
Lane
uh
I wish it becomes like those cartoon
chickens that lay a bunch of eggs
[Laughter]
right and then on that note
who picks who could beat Tom Hardy is he
had chat picks who did you guys decide
because see it's in blue but we don't
without pulling that never got pulled oh
yeah I don't know should we talk about
that amongst ourselves who do you guys
think would be toddler oh amongst the
four of us yeah I want no piece of him
yeah I would want to take on summer I
would I support you and I removed my
name I will wipe the blood from your
brows
my Polly I'll be the guy to slap
vaseline on your face
I'll wear like a weird Knights helmet
walking behind you with like the
chainmail and the sword
he's real life Wolverine okay and I want
I want nothing to do with him he's got a
low center of gravity and a lot of hair
uh
I have a I have a bad center of gravity
in him hairless we don't it's oil and
water me and Tom Hardy so true we tried
to give him a graft it didn't take
it my Hair It Is
in some countries we're legally married
thank you all so much uh for watching
today's episode thank you decoy Eric and
Tommy for being here uh if you made it
this far hit like hit subscribe we
appreciate you
um we'll be back tomorrow and the day
after and every weekday from here on out
JT Tice thank you so much almost to it
you know what Tommy maybe we can just
for JT can we break them off another
rant all right you got one you're
sitting on yeah sure I'll do one more
then I gotta go be peaceful get it out
all right uh Purge it out
this one's for all my gen Z homies this
microphone is not on
just a prop
I want to talk to you guys about Tick
Tock what's happening are you all okay
I I don't mind Tick Tock I'm in I'm on
it I'm trying to do some ticks and some
talks what is the deal with grown adults
making like fake Mysteries like we found
a box in my attic and we're gonna open
it up and it's a 19 part video that
part's fine I get it it's dramatic
you're creating a story that's fine
there's like two million views on it and
there are people responding to it as
though it's true as though like the
mystery box in the Attic is actually
real it does lead on a treasure hunt are
you guys all right are you just playing
along too is that part of the role play
also doing like a couple little side
steps in a bikini and then a wing to the
camera that's not a talent you don't get
a manager for that okay if that were a
town I'd have 15 managers all right can
we zoom in on this that's the beef
where's the beef there's the beef around
me two cheeks listen to me don't make me
start dancing with no shirt on Tick Tock
instead of working here I want to work
with you guys I want to do this show but
you're making it too easy to make money
on Tick Tock branded content there's
lunatics out there sponsored by like
Fisher Price
Hostess cupcakes
yo-yos for Christ's sakes all right in
the last but not least on Tick Tock the
last thing I'm going to say celebrities
you don't all got to get on there I
don't need to see some 75 year old actor
being like hey what's up my name is
Donovan the singer from the 50s and I'm
on Tick Tock now
or you're just rambling and shambing
like a corpse that's it thank you Tommy
wow I followed some of that it's a tick
tock down as Cody in the chat says also
don't cook your chicken in Nyquil that
one I actually do think is important
that's a universal I mean I know cold
and flu season's coming but come on guys
no seasoning how am I supposed to not be
congested and enjoy delicious chicken
I just cook it in zzquil oh
thank you so much for watching as uh
Bucky Barnes ATL said in the chat booty
beads keep it Gucci to moochie I think
that well said uh any investors in the
chat let's get on this vibranium anal
beads let's get it let's get it going
keep it Gucci anyone want to come over
and cook some NyQuil chicken with me
I'll be out tonight
chopping it up like Tom Hardy's
opponents I tap out
[Music]
it's true
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]